- [Instructor] We're told the quantities
x and y are proportional,
and then they give us a
table where they give us
a bunch of x's and they give
us the corresponding y's.
When x is four, y is 10.
When x is five, y is 12.5,
and so on and so forth.
Find the constant of proportionality, r,
in the equation y is equal to r times x.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right so we wanna find the constant,
the constant of proportionality,
I sometimes have trouble saying that,
r, where if I for any x,
if I multiply it by r I get y.
Well we just have to
look at each of these x's
and figure out well what
are we multiplying by
to get to y.
So what do I have to multiply
four by to get to 10?
Well if you multiply it by 10/4,
if you multiply it by 10/4,
then you're gonna get to 10.
And 10/4 is the same thing
as multiplying it by,
let's see that is 2 1/2.
So this is times 2 1/2.
So let's see does that hold?
In every case if I multiply by 2 1/2,
if I multiply x by 2 1/2, do I get y?
So five times 2 1/2,
five times two is 10, and
then another 1/2 is 2.5.
It indeed does equals 12.5.
Five times 2.5.
And then here 10 times 2.5
is clearly 25.
And you can work it out by hand.
I did the little bit of the
multiplication in my head,
but you can see in every case,
I take my x, I multiply
it by 2.5, I get my y.
So in every case I take
my x and multiply it
by the constant of
proportionality 2.5, I get my y.
So what's the constant of proportionality?
It is 2.5.